plans to break your knees coming into us
from Scotland uh Edinburgh 29 year old
man from Yorkshire has been found guilty
of murdering his wife in Edinburgh in
September 2021.
um Kashif Anwar was convicted at the
high court in Edinburgh today of
murdering 31 year old fawzi uh Jazzy
Javed rather at Arthur's seat in
Hollywood Park back in 2021
um detective inspector Bob Williamson
said this has been an incredibly
difficult and traumatic time for
fawzia's family who are understandably
devastated by her death fawzia was much
loved and had her life ahead of her with
a new baby on the way this was all
cruelly taken from her and her unborn
child at the hands of her own husband
someone who should have loved and
protected her and while his actions were
incomprehensible and as an
investigations team we welcome today's
verdict I sincerely hope that that he
has now been found guilty will afford
fazia's family and friends some sense of
justice so that is 29 year old Kashif
Anwar convicted today at the high court
in Edinburgh of murdering 31 year old
fawzia Javed at Arthur's seat Hollywood
Park back in 2021